sigamos estamos en la búsqueda de este
vector unitario tangente dada la
parametrización aquí tenemos un ejemplo
específico donde tengo una función que
parametrizar a un círculo con radio r
mayúscula y en un ejemplo paralelo
quiero mostrarte lo mismo pero más
abstracto veremos de manera más
abstracta lo que hicimos aquí para el
efecto unitario tangente tenemos lo
mismo aquí para el vector unitario
tangente que es igual a la derivada que
sabemos que nos da la tangente pero tal
vez no esté en su forma unitaria
entonces si no está lo normalizamos
tomando la magnitud de esa función de
vector tangente y en nuestro caso
específico con el círculo una vez que
tomamos las componentes al cuadrado y
luego hicimos las simplificaciones
necesarias obtuvimos la función r pero
en el caso general tal vez no tengamos
tanta suerte porque la magnitud de esta
derivada
será igual a la raíz cuadrada de x prima
de t al cuadrado es decir la componente
x de la derivada + y prima de t al
cuadrado lo que estoy haciendo es
tomando la magnitud del vector entonces
cuando tomó toda la función la dividido
entre su magnitud puedes ver que no se
simplifica como en el caso del círculo
aquí tenemos x prima de t y tenemos que
dividirla entre toda la magnitud todo lo
que era esta expresión que bueno para no
escribirla toda la pondré como raíz de
punto punto punto y similarmente tenemos
que prima de t entre toda esta expresión
entonces bueno puedes ver que la
simplificación no siempre ocurre no
siempre se da en este caso tuvimos un
poco de suerte en este caso del ejemplo
del círculo y ahora una vez
que tenemos el vector unitario tangente
como función del mismo parámetro lo que
queremos encontrar es la derivada del
vector unitario tangente con respecto a
la longitud de arco s y encontrar la
magnitud de eso pues es lo que nos dará
la curvatura y para hacer eso toma la
derivada con respecto al parámetro t
entonces tomás de t mayúscula de t
minúscula y lo dividimos entre la
derivada de nuestra función es con
respecto a t que ya habíamos encontrado
y ahora tal vez viendo aquí la notación
pienses que puedes cancelar las veces
pero otra manera de pensarlo es que
cuando tenemos nuestra función del
vector unitario como función de nuestro
parámetro t no conocemos cuál es el
cambio con respecto a ese pero si
conocemos su cambio con respecto a un
cambio pequeño en ese parámetro entonces
corrigiendo eso vemos que tanto cambio
la longitud de la curva mientras vas
cambiando ese parámetro y entonces bsd
te lo que nos indica es
para un lapso muy pequeño de tiempo el
tamaño de ese movimiento con respecto a
ese pequeño lapso de tiempo entonces la
razón por la que esto nos resulta un
vector muy largo es porque estás tomando
la razón aquí es decir tal vez este
cambio pequeño simboliza un vector muy
pequeño pero lo estás dividiendo entre
un número más pequeño y si tomáramos la
magnitud de esto será igual a r lo cual
resulta un tanto poético que la magnitud
de la derivada sea igual al radio ahora
nuestro caso específico lo que tenemos
aquí es en el ejemplo del círculo
tenemos en la función del vector
tangente tomamos la derivada de nuestro
vector tangente con respecto al
parámetro vemos que aquí el vector
unitario tangente tiene la forma de
menos seno dt i coseno de t entonces lo
que hacemos es tomar la derivada vamos a
tomar la derivada de menos 0 dt eso es
menos coseno de t
jaja y la derivada de coseno dt es menos
seno de t estamos simplemente
diferenciando nuestra función del vector
tangente y eso que implica tenemos
entonces la magnitud de la derivada del
vector tangente con respecto a t tomamos
la magnitud de eso y bueno que tenemos
en este vector tenemos coseno tenemos
cero así que bueno tendrás coseno
cuadrado de t más seno cuadrado de t
eso es igual a 1 por lo tanto esta
magnitud es igual a 1 ahora en el caso
general cuando dividimos entre la
magnitud de la derivada tomamos esto y
lo dividimos entre la magnitud de la
derivada
entonces tenemos
tenemos de ese sobre de té
que es igual a r recuerda así es como
obtuvimos la r tomamos aquí la derivada
y su magnitud y resultó ser r entonces
en el caso específico del círculo la
función de la curvatura que queremos es
es constantemente igual a 1 sobre r baja
lo cual es genial porque en el primer
vídeo te dije que la curvatura se define
como 1 sobre el radio del círculo que se
acerca más a la curva
y si tu curva es un círculo entonces el
círculo que se acerca más a la curva
bueno pues será el mismo por eso tenemos
uno sobre r ahora en el caso general tal
vez sea un poco un poco más difícil pero
veamos tenemos nuestra función del
vector tangente que es igual a esto un
tanto complicado donde donde esto que
tiene puntos es igual a esto de aquí x
prima de t al cuadrado más prima de t al
cuadrado ajá y a esto le sacará su
derivada con respecto a t
luego tomarás la magnitud de eso y lo
dividirán divididas todo eso entre la
magnitud de la derivada de tu función
original muy bien ahora todo eso no lo
haré en este vídeo
al menos no todos los pasos pero sí te
diré que esta fórmula que obtendrás será
será igual a x prima de t que es la
primer derivada de la primer componente
multiplicada por thievy prima de t
la segunda derivada de la segunda
componente menos de prima de t la
primera derivada de la segunda
componente x
xvii prima de té
y todo eso todo eso lo vas a dividir
entre la magnitud
x prima de té al cuadrado
más de prima de t al cuadrado elevado
todo a la tres medios y esto se obtiene
porque observa cuando tú tomas la
derivada de la función del vector
unitario tangente tienes este radical
que tiene x primas y primas y de ahí
tuvo obtienes las xvii primas y las
10.000 primas porque la regla de la
cadena te lleva por ese camino y ahí
tienes ese término pero elevado a la
tres medios ahora en el próximo vídeo
voy a describirte intuitivamente porque
esta fórmula si nos da la medida de la
curvatura en la curva baja recuerda que
primero te había dicho que la curvatura
se ve como como el círculo que más se
acerca a tu curva que más lo lo abraza
y tomabas 1 sobre ere y en esta otra
manera tu estás pensando en esto de tbs
es decir el cambio en el vector unitario
tangente con respecto a la longitud de
arco y estaba tomando su magnitud
recuerdas a sus maneras es a sus maneras
describen lo mismo exactamente lo mismo
ya veremos algún ejemplo donde
calculamos la curvatura de algo que no
sea un círculo para que lo veas más
claro